ob künstliche intelligenz ki jetzt gut
oder schlecht für die menschheit ist
darüber scheiden sich die geister
jetzt tut sich allerdings eine
perspektive auf die ist extrem spannend
und angefangen hat alles mit fast ray
burst also schnellen radio blitzen was
die mit außerirdischen zu tun haben
jetzt den klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt es täglich seines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen radio blitze
sogenannte raiders gehören wohl mit zu
den größten rätsel der astronomie
die ursache und der ursprung der extrem
intensiven fast raiders die sind
weitgehend unbekannt
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus den usa haben jetzt eine künstliche
intelligenz zur unterstützung
herangezogen und das ist wirklich irre
die ki hat nicht nur 72 weitere radio
blitze einer rund drei milliarden
lichtjahre entfernten quelle aufgespürt
ihre analysen liefern zudem auch super
spannende hinweise zu dem mysteriösen
phänomenen der radio blitze denn das was
wir bisher über die so genannten fast
track your body wissen hält sich
wirklich in grenzen was feststeht diese
radio blitze sind sehr intensiv und
halten nur millisekunden sie entstehen
wohl außerhalb unserer galaxie
doch wie genau das ist unklar der
großteil der bisher detektierten radio
blitze tritt vereinzelt auf die einzige
ausnahme davon ist fab 12 11 02 hier
konnten sich wiederholende ausbrüche
registriert werden 200 an der zahl
so gelang es dann auch endlich die
genaue quelle in diesem fall zu
identifizieren eine zwerggalaxien die
drei milliarden lichtjahre entfernt ist
hier vermuten die experten und
expertinnen ein extrem starkes
magnetfeld das schließen sie aus der
linearen polarisierung der radiosignale
die stark verdreht ist in der
fachsprache wird dieser effekt als
parade effekt bezeichnet und fab 12 11
nur zwei ist dieser eben mal 500 mal
stärker als bei allen anderen fast
regelwerks das hatte ein
niederländisches forschungsteam erst
anfang des jahres herausgefunden
doch um welches extrem starke magnetfeld
es sich handelt das ist noch völlig
offen um all die offenen fragen zu dem
mysteriösen phänomenen der radio blitze
zu beantworten hat ein forschungsteam
aus berkeley jetzt eine künstliche
intelligenz
als unterstützung hinzu geholt die ki
hatte die aufgabe die beobachtungsdaten
die das greenback radioteleskopen west
virginia im august 2017 sechs stunden
lang aufgezeichnet hatte auszuwerten
damit die analyse des neuronalen
netzwerk es brauchbare ergebnisse
liefert wurde die ki zunächst trainiert
und zwar mit daten zu simulierten und
echten radiobereich und tatsächlich zu
den 21 radio pulsen die man bislang
aufspielen konnte fand die weitere 72
radio kits von evb 12 11 02 sind nun
also insgesamt mehr als 300 radio blitze
bekannt dazu schreibt das us
forschungsteam wir präsentieren damit
die erste erfolgreiche anwendung von die
burning auf die detektion von stellen
radiosignalen in rohan speck
programmdaten unsere ergebnisse stellen
die bisher größte zahl von radium
blitzen innerhalb einer beobachtungszeit
taten doch die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vermuten noch eine
weitere große anzahl an radio blitzen
sie selbst der ki in ihrer analyse
entgangen sind ein hinweis darauf
liefert die verteilung der pulse über
den beobachtungszeitraum die stark von
einer zufalls verteilung abweicht und
die von dem neuronalen netzwerk
aufgespürten radio berg bringen etwas
licht in das mysteriöse phänomen
zum einen konnte das forschungsteam
feststellen dass knapp 50 prozent der
pulse in den ersten 30 minuten der
beobachtungszeit eingetroffen waren was
genau das bedeutet das blatt noch offen
diese beobachtung könnte allerdings ein
hinweis darauf sein dass es sich bei den
schwächeren pulse um eine art nachbeben
eines starken blitzes handelt ganz
auszuschliessen sei aber nicht dass es
sich dabei auch um ganz normale
schwankungen der radio emissionshandel
so das forschungsteam ein sehr konkretes
ergebnis lieferte die analyse der ki
bezüglich der regelmäßigkeit der radl
blitze die regelmäßigen intervalle in
denen sie auftraten sind kürzer als zehn
millisekunden so das ergebnis das
forschungsteam zudem zeigt die ki auch
dass die regiobus in einigen fällen sehr
eng aufeinander folgende paare bilden
eine äußerst wichtige frage zu der noch
weiter geforscht werden muss rotiert die
quelle der radio blitze oder nicht denn
die antwort darauf könnte spannende
rückschlüsse auf die mögliche quelle von
fab 12 11 02 zu lassen
bei einem rotierenden objekt das sehr
regelmässige pulse aussendet
könnte es sich beispielsweise um einen
millisekunden magnetare handeln das ist
ein schnell rotierenden neutronenstern
mit starken magnetfeldern doch das sind
nicht die einzigen möglichen quellen
forschungsteams hatten auch schon einmal
schwarze löcher oder hast du ihnen
einschläge auf neutronensternen ins
spiel gebracht die fachwelt jedenfalls
feiert die arbeit des us forschungsteams
dazu der wissenschaftler andrew simeon
und das ist extrem gespannt was er sagt
diese arbeit ist sehr aufregend und zwar
nicht nur weil sie uns hilft das
dynamische verhalten schneller radiowelt
genauer zu verstehen
diese forschung ist sehr
vielversprechend bezüglich dem einsatz
von ki mit der man signale erkennen kann
die klassische algorithmen verpasst
haben moment signale erkennen kann die
klassische algorithmen verpasst haben
nämlich die von aliens der forscher ist
nämlich teil des sogenannten brics
kulissen projekt zu sein privat
finanziertes forschungsprojekt das sich
der suche nach außerirdischem leben im
all verschrieben hat auch in diesem
zusammenhang wird ki angewandt sie soll
signale aufspüren die von außerirdischen
zivilisationen stammen könnten und
vielleicht könnte so ein durchbruch
erzielt werden denn ki ist der einzige
weg riesige datenmengen nach strukturen
eben zum beispiel signalen von
außerirdischen zu durchsuchen und
trainieren könnte man die auch hier auf
der erde
sie könnte radiosignale oder funksignale
auf der erde suchen und damit lernen und
vielleicht könnte so ein durchbruch
erzielt werden denn ki ist der einzige
weg riesige datenmengen nach strukturen
eben zum beispiel signalen von
außerirdischen zu durchsuchen und
trainieren könnte man die ki auch hier
auf der erde
sie könnte radiosignale oder funksignale
auf der erde suchen und damit lernt
diese entdeckung könnte wirklich ein
riesiger schritt sein auf dem weg der
entdeckung von aliens denn auch wenn es
wahrscheinlich unzählige zivilisationen
da draußen gibt sie in den
wahrscheinlich milliarden mal mehr
anderen signalen zu entdecken ist eine
riesige herausforderung das künstliche
intelligenz hier bei den radio über so
einen unterschied macht ist mehr als
vielversprechend und ich bleibe dran und
wenn ihr garantiert kein video dazu und
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann hilft nur whatsapp da informiere
ich euch täglich und das vor allen
andern
dafür hier klicken und weiter geht's mit
auch dafür drauf klicken wird ein gamma
blitz die erde zerstören der elster
blitz aller zeiten das erste video
übrigens von klicks um science-fiction
bis da bleibt dran